great I'm doing excellent listen this is
a great great powerful important movie
how quickly did you say yes to the
script
I said yes probably before they did I
was like as soon as I got it I read it
connecting with the work and
understanding Brian's work sigh meeow
yeah I mean mine was pretty quick too
but it was like a the steps were you
know Dustin giving me the script me
reading it I mean calling him afterwards
being like this is amazing and I know
you want me to do this cuz you're my
brother but does Michael want me to do
it and he was like yeah I wanted to do
it I was like okay great I'm in cuz I
was just the only thing for me is it
felt like I knew what my piece was in
this film and it was really just to like
be there to hold space for Michael and I
wanted to make sure that I was the
person that he wanted to be there for
him while he was going through his
journey and so to be asked to do that I
just felt really honored so of course it
was yes yeah Brian's story is
unbelievable what when you I'm how much
did you know about Brian's story and how
much did it sort of floor you just to
know and learn what kind of impact he's
had on so many people's lives I I am
still floored by Brian the more that I
learn about what he's doing the more
that I see I went to Montgomery to visit
eji and to visit the memorial and the
museum and just to see the far-reaching
aspects of how he is changing our
understanding as people in this country
and worldwide how he is changing how we
we think and how we engage around these
topics I am I am continuously floored I
didn't know a whole lot I knew that he
had an organization in that and Alan
but I did not understand the impact that
he was having that he's had for over 30
years in our country so I'm really
excited that this film amplifies what
he's doing he's been doing the work he
and his team we just get a chance to
tell the story exactly I knew about his
work through Destin actually while we
were doing another film together the the
glass castle we were had like just
gotten we've just gotten to Montreal and
grabbed dinner and we were just having
like our normal sort of talking about
the world and humanity discussions and
he was like you should read this book
trust mercy I think like it's gonna
upset you but I also think ultimately
you're gonna feel really good it'll give
you some positive fuel and so I bought
it directly after that dinner and he was
right I remember just feeling like
almost feverish reading it like hot it
made me feel so much but then it's true
and in particular by the end of it I
felt like so much gratitude to him and
that there was so much that could be
done and that I could participate and so
that is stuck with me for many years and
then to be part of this film just felt
like a great extension of my lifelong
work of being a student of Bryan
Stevenson I know I got to go but real
quick the one thing I've sort of want to
commend Warner Brothers on and everyone
involved is this is a hard film to get
made you know everyone I mean I love
superhero movies but movies like this
are so important you know what I mean if
you could you're sort of touch on that
oh I mean I feel like you you said it
all I mean these are these are movies
that you know change people's mind
change people's hearts and allow them to
look at people that maybe they thought
they had nothing in common with and
realize they have everything in common
with I mean there are human lives at
stake right now and there are people
that can watch this movie that can do
something to change that and and so you
can't you can't put a price tag on that
that's kind of beyond anything and truly
for me that's what I believe art is here
to do